vous êtes pour vendre la peine de mort
madame justice
les gens qui donnent la mort là méritent
aussi ses propos face caméra n'était pas
rare à l'époque c'était en 1970 c'est la
majorité des français et pour la peine
de mort mais certains prônent son
abolition des manifestations
s'organisent les personnalités milite à
l'image de l'avocat robert badinter en
1976 des ss n y en aura toujours mais
une société qui veut avancer cette
société-là doit se dépasser et refuser
la loi du talion la peine de mort sinon
elle ne progressera al'inverse lui et
pour la peine capitale c'est michel
poniatowski le ministre de l'intérieur
de l'époque toujours en 1976 il se mêle
publiquement aux débats lors de l'
affaire patrick henry un homme jugé
coupable du meurtre d'un enfant de 7 ans
et je vous dirais que j'étais juré je me
prononcerai pour la paix
l'avocat de patrick henry n'est autre
que robert badinter janvier 77 lors de
son procès le meurtrier échappe à la
guillotine
vers dit réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
je ne crois pas qu'il faille dire que la
peine de mort est abolie parce que
patrick henry n'a pas été condamné à
mort
vous êtes en présence d'une décision
mais la peine de mort est toujours là
lui aussi il va aller à l'encontre de
l'avis général des français françois
mitterrand en mars 1981 le candidat
socialiste à la présidentielle en fait
une promesse électorale dans ma
conscience dans le fort de la confiance
de ma conscience je suis contre la peine
de mort
malgré ses déclarations
françois mitterrand est élu président de
la république dès le début de son mandat
il nomme robert badinter garde des
sceaux le 17 septembre 1981 l'ancien
avocat présente son projet de loi sur
l'abolition de la peine capitale devant
l'assemblée nationale j'ai l'honneur
au nom du gouvernement de la république
de demander à l'assemblée nationale
l'abolition de la peine de mort en
france
la peine de mort est contraire à ce que
l'humanité depuis 2000 ans à penser de
plus haut et rêver de plus noble elle
est contraire à la foi à l'esprit du
christianisme et à l'esprit la
révolution après trois semaines de
débats parlementaires la peine de mort
est abolie le 9 octobre 1981
[Musique]